اثارت قضيه انفجار مرفا بيروت غضب الشارع
اللبناني مجددا
عندما مدخل قصر العدل اصطدم محتجون مع قوى
الامن قبيل اجتماع لمجلس القضاء الاعلى
فهؤلاء يعتقدون ان التطورات القضائيه
الاخيره تهدف الى تنحيه المحقق العدلي في
قضيه المرفق طارق البيطار
للعداله والحقيقه وبدنا نحسبهم للمجرمين
لكن مجلس القضاء على سلطه قضائيه في لبنان
والذي كان من المفترض ان يناقش القرارات
الاخيره التي اتخذها المحقق العدلي فشله
في الالتئام
المجلس القضاء الاعلى علي مسؤوليه يشرح
المشروع بيصير داخل القضاء
ومن القوانين هستيريا قضائيه
قانونيه ومش عارفين كيف بدنا نوقف ونعطي
امل للناس وبيهذا استمرت قرارات النائب
العام ساريه المفعول بكفي يد القاضي
البيطار عن القضيه والادعاء عليه بتهمه
اغتصاب السلطه
العدلي مخالفه للقانون ويؤكد استمراره في
عمله حتى اصداره القرار الاتهامي في
القضيه
هذه المواجهه القضائيه بين نيابه العامه
والمحقق العدلي اثارات الخشيه من
ارتداداتها على مجمل العمل القضائي في
لبنان
حياته كان في قرارات هل قد متناقضه لدرجه
انه صافين انتماء شخصيه بين الاوضاعات
على ملف القضيه
وما بعرف لوين بدها توصل
كل هذا يترقبوا اهالي الضحايا تحديدا موعد
جديد اجتماعي مجلس القضاء الاعلى مجلس
يحمل بداخله بذور مواجهه مرتبه بسبب
الخلافات بين اعضائه بشان كيفيه مقاربه
القرارات القضائيه المتباينه في ملف
انفجار المرفق زادت من تعقيدات القضيه
التي لم يصدر فيها قرار اتهاما بعد نحو
عامين ونصف على الانفجار وعززت خشيه اهالي
الضحايا من طي صفحه التحقيق دون كشف
ملابساتها ومحاكمه المتورطين فيها ايهاب
العقد الجزيره بيروت